- Ines Ben Said a reçu un avis
d'éviction le mois dernier.
Ses voisins - des femmes
monoparentales, des réfugiés et
des aînés - devront aussi
partir. Le propriétaire demande
de quitter le 1er juillet,
pour une période de 9 mois.
Il évoque des rénovations
majeures.
INES BEN SAID, locataire
- Depuis, on vit dans
un calvaire qui ne finit pas,
il y a des gens qui ne dorment
plus la nuit, il y a des gens
qui pensent : comment on va
faire, où on va aller, on a
essayé de parler avec
nos enfants, y en a qui
comprennent pas.
- Les histoires de ce genre se
multiplient. Comme ici
dans l'arrondissement
de Saint-Léonard, où les ménages
sont vulnérables.
Hamza Mousti en est un exemple.
Il craint de perdre son
appartement rue Jean-Talon.
HAMZA MOUSTI, locataire
- La plupart des locataires
ont un salaire moyen, je dirais
même 100 %, ce qui fait que de
trouver un logement pour doubler
les prix, c'est incroyable.
- Un propriétaire
peut légalement évincer ses
locataires s'il veut agrandir,
subdiviser ou changer
l'affectation de son logement.
Selon le tribunal administratif
du logement, les locataires
doivent être indemnisés.
HANS BROUILLETTE, Corporation
des propriétaires immobiliers Qc
- Il arrive forcément que
durant la vie utile
d'un immeuble, les locataires
aient à subir les inconvénients
de travaux majeurs.
On sait aussi qu'on a
des lois qui nous imposent
de faire des vérifications,
de faire des améliorations.
- Mais cette association qui
représente les locataires estime
que certains propriétaires
évincent illégalement
sous prétexte de rénovations.
MAXIME ROY-ALLARD Regroupement
des comités logement, Qc
- Comme les immeubles
nécessitent souvent des travaux
parce qu'il y a eu un laxisme
d'entretien, on va utiliser
ce prétexte-là.
- Pour contrer ce qu'on appelle
les rénovictions, certains
arrondissements de Montréal
ont resserré les critères
pour obtenir des permis.
ANDRÉ ÉMARD,
avocat à l'aide juridique
- C'est un changement que
s'il pouvait être uniforme,
partout à Montréal ou partout
au Québec, c'est sûr que
ça ferait un gros, gros
changement et je crois que
c'est la première qu'il faudrait
qui soit faite.
- Mais on presse aussi
le gouvernement
du Québec d'agir.
- Faut venir modifier le code
civil pour rendre plus difficile
toutes formes d'évictions.
- La ministre de l'Habitation
planche plutôt sur une autre
solution : renverser le fardeau
de la preuve pour qu'il incombe
aux propriétaires de démontrer
le bien fondé des rénovations.
ANDRÉE LAFOREST, ministre
des Affaires municipales, Québec
- Le locataire, lui, qu'est-ce
qu'il doit faire, c'est qu'il a
le fardeau de prouver qu'il a
été évincé. Est-ce que c'est
vraiment le locataire qui doit
prouver qu'il a été évincé
ou encore, on pourrait
transférer le fardeau de
la preuve au propriétaire.
- Impossible de savoir à quel
moment le changement sera fait.
D'ici là, les locataires
devront continuer de se défendre
au Tribunal administratif
du logement.
Même si la suite s'annonce
difficile, Ines Ben Said
est décidée à rester chez elle.
Elle veut contester
jusqu'au bout.
- C'est même pas d'en discuter.
Personnellement, je ne veux pas
quitter. Et c'est le cas de la
majorité.
- Ici Aimée Lemieux,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.